Hugh Jackson's the former Browns Raiders
head coach and he will be leading the
Colin Kaepernick workout at the Falcons
facility tomorrow joining us in the
Continental Tire Coaches Corner and
coach I was going to ask you about Colin
Kaepernick but let me ask you about your
former team what did you see last night
with Miles Garrett well I was a little
surprised that's not becoming of mouths
I hadn't saw that so you know I'd be
obviously it's inexcusable and I know he
feels bad about it he's that kind of guy
he I'm a little surprised that it went
as far as it did but at the same time
those things shouldn't and can't happen
in the league and I'm sure the league
will take a stand on it what do you
think they do
what's an applicable punishment here you
know I don't know I don't have that
particular answer I know anywhere from
you know four games to the rest of the
season or you know one hefty fines I
mean I hadn't seen that happen in the
National Football League but I can
definitely say that's not mouths
Garrett's character somehow somewhere
you know I just think he lost it for a
second you know he lost his cool and did
something that's inexcusable
and pounce he's probably going to get
suspended as well for his role in
protecting Mason Rudolph but if you were
Mike Tomlin and your offensive lineman
did that last night
what would you say to him today well I
would tell him he needs to be smarter
but I would understand because he
watched one of his teammates take a blow
with a helmet to the head and that he
reacted you know he was trying to do
everything he could to protect his
teammate who says that he wasn't going
to get hit again you know so at that
point I've been around guys that they
get in those situations and then they
just see red once those things happen
they go on the other side and they can't
get back into everything stopped so I
get it moving forward if you were going
to invest in the Browns or the Steelers
making the playoffs even though the
Browns won last night who do you think's
got a better chance well oh the right
does the schedule for the Browns is set
up nice form you know I think it's going
to be about you know do they
miles Garrett at all the rest of the
year you know and it's going to be very
injuries as they continue to go through
the season and obviously Pittsburgh
defense is playing well they got to find
their offensive rhythm but right down
the Browns or two-and-oh in the division
they've beat both Baltimore in
Pittsburgh so this seems like they have
the easier road to get there
what is Cleveland missing on offense I
don't know that they're missing anything
dan I I think it's just they got a play
with a little bit more cohesiveness I
should say and a little bit more rhythm
I think that's what people would look
for I mean they opened a game and had an
unbelievable Drive you know that led to
a score and then you know they didn't
play as well you know so there's
consistency and doing things right all
the time it's probably what was needed
to have a better offensive performance
he's huge Jackson former NFL head coach
and he will have a role in Colin
Kaepernick's work out at the Falcons
facility tomorrow what is your role
tomorrow coach well delete the workout
you know I'm excited about having the
opportunity I know Colin you know when
he was coming out I'm nevada-reno and
obviously a sensational player and a
really good person and spend time with
him that way wish we had drafted him at
the Raiders and obviously I've watched
his career you know the guy who played
in the Super Bowl so he's very talented
I could make all the throws I know when
he was coming out he's very athletic and
I'm just you know delighted to have an
opportunity to be a part of this it's a
long layoff though coach not playing
football oh no it is you know there's no
question about that you know and
obviously competitive football at that
too but Tim in my mind just knowing
Colin a little bit if any guy can do it
it's him you know I've seen guys take
time off before and it sometime they
come back better up saying guys that
take time off and they don't come back
at all
so somewhere in there is where he will
be more important the interview process
or the workout in your opinion I think
it's the workout I think this is about
the workout I think all the other things
that need to be talked about they
we'll be in time but I think that's
somewhat behind us let's find out if he
has the skill and desired a
determination to play at this level
again and that will somewhat show itself
and then I'm sure everybody else who has
the interest will dive into the other
things that need that they need to dive
into do you think there is a team right
now that wants to sign Colin Kaepernick
before this workout even happens I think
there are I mean I think people wanted
to know more about where he is you know
as far as football does he still have
the arm talent the athleticism that he's
shown before I think this you know gives
the league an opportunity to put some of
the things that have happened behind us
you know and move forward and if his
skill level is where it needs to be
hopefully this leads to an opportunity
of him playing again in the National
Football League
what is the one drill if you were a
coach who was going to Scout him that
you want to see how well he performs in
you guys really interesting dad because
I think the most important thing will be
his you know his conditioning you know
and he still has the arm talent you know
if you know there's a lot of people like
you said you know you've been out of
football for quite a while have you
really worked at a level that's going to
give you a chance to go into a National
Football League organization and compete
at a high level and most guys is really
interesting or normally out of shape
they're not in football shape you know
to make you know 6070 throws drop back
that many times being a shotgun and have
the mental discipline that it takes to
play at a high level plan and play out
that's gonna be really important does he
run a forty I don't know that I have not
been a part of that part of the
discussion you know my thing will be
leading the drills as far as throwing
and then things will last quarterback to
do on the field coach great to talk to
you have fun tomorrow and we appreciate
your time thank you I appreciate it
that's Hugh Jackson he's the former
Browns head coach Continental Tire
coaches corner no matter what you drive
where you drive how you drive
Continental has a tire for you more
information Continental Tire dot-com
Continental Tire for what you
- for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]